In Unit 5 we briefly mentioned dead reckoning.
Dead reckoning is the method that mariners used to use to estimate their position at sea.
They did this by keeping a log book of the direction they were heading,
they speed they were moving at, and the duration that they moved at that speed and direction.
In one particular journey where a ship wants to get from start to finish
the ship starts out by going east at a speed of 12 k/h for 2.5 hours.
The ship then heads south at 20 m/h for 1 hour,
east at 15 m/h for 3 hours and then finally northeast at 8 k/h for 1 hour.
My question is what's the straight-line distance between start and finish.
By straight-line distance, I mean this distance from start to finish.
Not the total distance the ship traveled, because the ship took a slightly inefficient route.
Now, this is a sort of tricky problem, but as long as you keep track of your trignometry
and geometry, and you will have to make some right triangles,
you'll be able to get this one right. Enter your answer here in kilometers.